riga is the baltic state's largest city
it's home to some seven hundred thousand
residents
there's a stender store right in the
center
java iglita co-founded the cosmetics
company 12 years ago
she first gives me an insight into the
world of soap oh and
these are different kind of soaps very
nice looking very nice smells
special ones with some herbs with some
honey
and you can see here that it's not just
about the soap
it's also about the colors and smells
and about the touches
it's a main our philosophy is that there
are
many sense for human being to to
to feel this is zero max's second
meeting with yeva
i show her our report from 2005.
last time we also visited the standards
manager in riga
she was 25 at the time and already
responsible for around 40 stores across
europe her plan then was to conquer the
world
and she did there are now 230 stender
stores in 23 countries
and more than 300 products ranging from
shampoo massage oils and creams
to gold dust soap
today java wants to show me her riga we
begin in the city center that was
granted world heritage status by unesco
in 1997.
the bustle is too much for her she
prefers quieter places
such as bastion hill the park on the
edge of the old city was built more than
a hundred years ago
we arrive at one of eva's favorite
places the roof terrace on the albert
hotel
from up here we have a great view of the
entire city
you were born here in in the city um
what do you like the most about riga
i think that there is a nice mixture of
different places different
kind of architecture and i think that
riga is still a very small city
and quite comparing with some other
capitals in europe so
i think that i can feel here still
very private and comfortable
next eva shows me the city's art nouveau
architecture
over a third of the centre's buildings
were designed in this style
earning riga the nickname of capital of
art nouveau
many have been done up in the last 20
years since the fall of the soviet union
and latvian independence
actually right now you can see a lot of
these buildings which are really
renovated because a lot of them were in
really bad conditions
like uh like uh ruined with the doors
joined and and everything like
in in riga there are more than 800 you
can sell buildings
we continue our tour of the city by car
going past the national library
eva wants to show me her company's
headquarters
the employees are learning how to
decorate gift boxes here
i take a crash course and now have the
perfect prize for the euromag straw
we continue our journey along the river
delgado away from the center
yeva takes me to another place that is
off the beaten track
ostaskati is a restaurant located in a
new office complex that serves dishes
made with regionally sourced ingredients
we ordered the filet of beef with
vegetables
and finally we go to another favorite
district
the industrial harbor area many
galleries and studios have cropped up
here recently
as have bars and restaurants
our last stop today is koya
veglite comes here often it's another
oasis of calm in riga
in her opinion one of the most beautiful
cities in the world